so you can hear the wind behind me rimix
I'm here with my my dogs and cats are
inside at our little carriage house
apartment here in hudson valley in new
york and things are starting to pick up
a bit we're not we're not suffering the
same sort of thing as the lower hudson
valley is imploding yet we're on pretty
high ground here so i don't think we're
gonna have too much trouble but you can
see that the wind is really starting to
blow the rain is starting a little bit
to drizzle and we're expecting a long
rough day maybe going on until wednesday
you know big issue that i have to worry
about is losing power because unless the
tree actually falls into my apartment
i'm not going to get flooded and there's
not too much else that's really going to
affect things but the dogs don't really
like the wind too much they're a little
bit nervous i'm actually going to take
this as an opportunity since i don't
have class and might you know I'm not
likely to have class maybe even thursday
i'll take this as an opportunity to
catch up on some reading and get some
writing projects done and so on to power
holds out there's no writing i do on my
laptop
sort of treat starting to crack a little
bit so I'm actually going to take this
as an opportunity to I think read
through Descartes meditations instruct
me on the way home from the store
earlier today the stores mom by the way
of course because they always are around
this time you know des cartes
meditations he's writing with this
narrative framework if I was in this
stove heated room and snowed in and I
had some time to myself to think about
things and that's kind of a nice nice
way to approach it it's almost like
going on a retreat and so I think I'm
actually going to reread the meditations
which I try to do at least you know once
a semester and so this would be a good
time to do that nice and quiet no
distractions maybe after the power goes
out good time to do that I might even do
a little filming depending on how the
how the lighting holds up so but I also
have some some Heidegger to outline and
read and I've got some other
existentialist office to work on I've
got some WD Ross handouts to make for my
students who I've got things set up so
they long as they have power they can
still do class we've got online forums
I've got videos for them to watch
handouts lessons so they should be okay
my main issue is what's going to happen
out here and I see the wind is now
starting to blow a lot of things
sideways not too bad right here Cooper
shelf
you can see the wind blowing the trees a
little bit further on especially that
we'll all right there that's a most
Pines those are kind of getting the
brunt of it hopefully we won't have
trees coming down
Oh storm isn't too bad yet but the dogs
are kind of excited about the warm it
looks like come on
you can see the wind is blowing the
trees we're on a bottom of a ridge line
so you can see a little bit better there
so we're pretty sheltered but the winds
are coming over the ridge line and
pushing the tops of the trees around not
too bad so far we're looking at maybe
30 mile per hour winds we're supposed to
get up to 70 mile-per-hour winds but
this area is going to be relatively
sheltered we hope from from Hurricane
sandy so I've got the dogs out now for a
little bit of exercise before the storm
actually hits so that they're going to
be cooped up for a day or so they'll be
all right